despite us somewhat quiet release in
December of 2015
Rainbow six siege has defied
conventional wisdom when it comes to
multiplayer growth rather than slowly
losing players in the months after
launch siege has all but exploded
becoming one of the most popular modern
video games at e3 in June Ubisoft
announced it had crossed 35 million
players worldwide of course with that
explosion comes the growing pains of
managing a community with so many people
signing in to siege every day there are
bound to be a few bad eggs so to speak
toxic players relying on anonymity to
behave negatively and to use harsh
language over the course of a match or
two this is nothing new games such as
Counter Strike Team Fortress dota 2 or
overwatch have encountered similar
problems throughout the years greater
numbers mean a higher chance of toxic
players making their way into the
community today no one is more familiar
with that problem than the team behind
Rainbow six siege and like other
developers before them they're
constantly looking for creative ways to
make sure their thriving community is
welcoming as well so we figured what
better place to catch up with the
Rainbow Six development team than here
in Paris at the Rainbow six majors where
the positive side of their community is
thriving
[Music]
it is indeed a factor that you see in
every popular multiplayer game toxicity
is not a fight that you will win it's
not a race that you will win that you're
raised oh that you have to take the best
job that you can do is actually try to
negate as much as possible all of those
side the negative effects that toxicity
brings toxicity you'll find it in many
different levels from certain elements
of gameplay that are creating
potentially some toxic behaviors team
kill for instance is a side effect of
friendly fire that's in the game so as a
developer when I take that particular
example you ask yourself hey I can
remove team kill 100% by removing
friendly fire but friendly fire at the
same time is as you play Rainbow six is
an element of tensions an element of
watching how you aim and how you shoot
so you always have to balance some of
your decision that gameplay or the game
can be itself a factor of toxicity then
the traditional toxicity that you find
in any online community that is the
usual racial homophobic slurs people
that are raging insulting people on
audio or chat and for this we have taken
I think two major measures one a couple
of months ago when we are banning
everyone that is actually on track using
homophobic and racial slurs and now
having the mute shot giving the ability
for any player to mute the text/chat of
any other player that may
took seeking how we how we write so I
discuss with you about something are you
are you man or you know you only need
one percent of a toxic community of
toxic population to actually ruin
everyone's experience because we are by
nature a multiplayer game so if one out
of the ten player is toxic that's all of
the players that are getting impacted by
it so I think we need to have a strong
stance about those behaviors so you have
already that mechanic OFAC one two three
then Haman sorry but I there are though
some instances that I mentioned before
like Ouma phobic and racial slurs its
direct permanent cheating direct comment
they are like behaviors that we have a
person come down and don't want even to
give a second chance when it comes to
this because they have too much of
drastic impacts on the rest of the on
the rest of the ecosystem
ceej isn't the only game fighting this
battle massive multiplayer titles such
as dota 2 and League of Legends have
been waging their own wars against toxic
players throughout the years and as Remi
is quick to point out the fight against
toxicity is about more than just
discouraging negative behavior it's also
about encouraging the exact opposite
there's also several measure that we are
thinking about on how you not only
punish but also try to educate the
people of how to better behave there are
examples that we don't that we like very
much in other games like the penalty -
for instance meaning that someone who
has been for several times toxic as a
penalty get on a special matchmaking -
where he sort of has to behave properly
for a certain amount of times or games
before I can actually join back the
public matchmaking or ranked matchmaking
and those are ideas that I found very
very interesting in the sense that
fighting toxicity is not only and purely
about punishment it's about the balance
between that punishment and the
education and that's something that we
have to develop I think one of the game
that we have been looking or has been a
source of inspiration has been daughter
and League of Legends that are two games
that are having I'd say some
similarities thanks to the heroes /
operators in our case so they are
already also in mobile as well as you
know and boutiques
a form of toxicity that is that comes
from the peak of the operator you have a
favorite character all of a sudden
that's someone else in my team that
picks it and I don't have access to my
character so all of and some of the
measures that those games have put in
place are very interesting for us to
watch not on all of them are applicable
but some of them are very very
interesting the penalty to that mention
is part of dota 2 and I believe has been
doing pretty great for the game the
reporting functions that you see in both
of those games are with more granularity
and more better ways to define the type
of offense or toxic behavior that you're
facing is also something that you are
looking at closely and we we feel is
important to have in the future we have
always wanted to feature a cast of
character that is very diverse that's
why every of the person's opera season
has a one female one male operator we
are visiting like so much different
countries ethnicities etc so that's
something that we feel was very
important to bring diversity within the
cast of our characters especially in
fantasy about context that can be very
serious and we are extremely happy and
extremely proud to take liberties with
reality in most of the units of special
forces that we feature in the game a lot
of them actually do not accept female
operators for instance also we have
give no damn about that rule and we
rather have diversity at the number one
objective versus authenticity if you
will and you are also mentioning the
diversity of the eSport scene and the
caster's of the talents that are
involved
I am extremely extremely proud of what
that the game has achieved on that
matter I don't believe that has yet a
measurable impact on you know on how
people behave in general but I do hope
that the image that it projects for the
fans for the media for anyone who's
watching is a positive image and it's a
you know long-term investment that
should pay off at the end of the wrestle
I'll tell you this is for Earth
developers fascinating because this is
the first instance for us where as game
developers you only think about
designing a mechanical map a character's
story whatever for most of us in the dev
team today this is our first one we are
facing questions about designing
mechanics instances or features to deal
with how people behave trust me the
human interaction is clearly more
complex than any of the other design
that we can think about whether it's an
operator a map organ a story so all of
that requires that we ask questions that
deep down a question that every citizen
ask itself
you mentioned the parallel with Twitter
or any other social media how how much
can you actually push banning what are
the criteria do you need a one two three
strikes
second chances all of those questions
that are fundamentally interesting back
because there are questions about
ourselves
they are the questions about society but
respect about living together but
animosity etc so it's fascinating and
clearly we will never get right the
answers will try will fail will adapt
and I'm sure Twitter Facebook and the
other in a similar situation where
honestly it is so I wouldn't say
subjective but it's so difficult as a
question philosophical question to grasp
that it's going to be a lot of trial at
all before you end up having solution
that that that maybe will last a
slightly longer on instruments
[Music]